chips mit hallo meine lieben freunde und
willkommen zu einer weiteren hunger
games folge ich weiß seitdem autos
direkt neben mir übrigens zusammen mit
dem dominik übrigens wieder mit dem
display oder kontrast das bist du
studieren ich dachte schon etwas wie das
ok es gibt da meinte nämlich gerade
jemand auf diesem server hier congo
after bitter der echte und wir haben so
lange gebraucht um server zu finden wo
uns keiner erkennt blieb ja meine lieben
freunde eigentlich wollten wir ja hunger
games auf diesem server aufnehmen aber
irgendwie nervt dass don hier schon ein
wenig auf der aufnahme und deswegen
einfach mal geschrieben
wir sind also sorry an dich wenn du das
er gerade sieht na ja wir sind hier auf
einem amerikanischen server und wir
werden hunger games spielen das wird
sich irgendwie bei mir auf dem kanal
wird das eine serie werden dass ich
immer mal so mit ein paar anderen
spielen werde öfters auch mit mit dem
hier mit dem exorzisten exorzisten der
hat was gegen bayer
jedenfalls müssen wir dann mal schauen
wie das wird ich habe ja früher schon
mal gemacht und jetzt los wir laufen
würde ich sagen direkt in mitte man hat
keines poncet glaube ich halte diese
sind ja alle schon oben an den kisten
okay die schlangen alter das musst du
mir drin
nein ok jetzt mache ich gar nichts was
ich will den einen hat nachkommen
stiftland effekt mit kommen kommentiert
wir haben sie mich liebst du mich ja
doch bitte sofort hinterher ich hoffe
nur dass uns kein hinterherläuft alter
weil sonst wären wir richtig gemacht
das sind jetzt gebiet also die
anfangszeit wo wir gucken müssen dass
uns kein hinterherläuft dass wir nicht
abrücken
beim anfangs sterben
ist hinter mir her machen übrigens team
weil das darf man hier teilweise sollte
die haben drei leute team und alt und
noch 527 tribute das ist übrigens ein
abruf 48 leute drin sind was heißt hier
laufen erst mal hier zu den rennern
ich hab irgendwann bekommt sozusagen wie
schon beim besten kommt auf die inseln
gut dann kann uns auf jeden fall keiner
mehr verfolgen ich hasse diesen stress
am anfang wenn es ganz schlimm
ja das ist einer der einzigen server die
mittlerweile keine am anfang des
friedens pause haben von so ein paar
sekunden weil es schon schrecklich am
anfang geht es darum die einnehmen was
aus dem ton und die nix mehr kriegen
sind gefrustet und haben diana nieder so
da vorne siehst du in la masia ist eine
kiste so weit ich weiß also ich habe
gerade eine minimap drauf der minimap
ist erlaubt es orientierung auch auf den
servern ist nun keine hacks erlaubt ja
nicht problemlos zu bekommen
ich wollte euch leute die fragen ob wir
das auf ihrem server war also eigentlich
müsste die immer nur gucken ob der
server gecrackt ist oder nicht
weil wenn der server crack ist euro was
tut man ja ich habe einen kuchen für
dich gemacht dass ich habe auch ein
kuchen habe so da ich geb dir meine hose
und ich bin immer schon und ich hab noch
ein boot schuhe ich habe auch noch
schuhe ja ich habe aber kein schwert das
ist ja ich auch nicht das ist doof also
leute wenn irgendwen irgendwie exorzist
oder kontrakte auf einem server sieht
fragt euch immer erst ab der gecrackt
ist und wenn dann nicht gekränkt ist
dann bin ich auf jeden fall und werner
gecrackt es dann bin ich auf jeden fall
nicht oder halb die anschreiben oder in
die sowas ja aber das soll ich das thema
sein sondern kämpfen hier ums überleben
guck mal hier so schafft man denken dass
auch noch was da könnte auch was sein da
hinten wird auf jeden fall was sein weil
er ist ein komischer touren aber ich
will auch nicht sprinten hat auch ich
habe ihr noch ein kuchen von daher ich
habe auch noch ein fisch für dich oh
danke der ich dann genauso wie meine
füße stimmt da hinten ist und wie sie
denn dass auch das weiß ich aber da
hinten ist auch so ein komischer gang in
der wand den sich auch
da wo ich ihn schlage rookies und da
sind auch tintenfisch thaddäus erinnert
sich ja immer meinen scanner der die
jost ag als teil ihres depots
die sind echt ist raus ja von den
dorfbewohnern und diesmal gab diese nase
echt krass aber die nase an sich ist
schon richtig lang genauso wie das ok
gut da oben ist eine kiste drin ich
werde der erste sein was wie komme ich
da hoch ich schon weg auch noch hunger
games server wo man sachen abbauen kann
oder ja die gibt's die haben dann aber
nicht mehr diese website
ach so ja das stimmt ja mein anderes ich
versuche jetzt erstmal nicht mehr zu
sprinten weil ich mir das dann nachher
für die leute der auf bewahre uns
brauchst ich habe einen helm gut aber
sonst nichts richtiges kein schwert denn
der nach wenn wir den hund sehen könnte
ich den wir holen weil ich hab so einen
knochen ok warten was hatte ich glaube
hinten war auch noch immer was immer
hinter den inseln also gucken ja schon
ich glaube der ok hier hinter der insel
ist jetzt nichts aber es könnte auf den
bäumen ist was dann glaube ich jetzt
aber auch nicht
wir könnten einfach mal da hinten
rüberschwimmen dahin viele nicht mehr
mein brot auch juristisch erschwert hier
ist ein komischer gang aber jetzt nichts
drin jetzt seltsam
na gut es ist doch wir können einfach
gucken am rand weil hier sind manchmal
echt sagen komische ja hier schon wieder
so eine einkerbung so komische löchern
versteckt man sonst hier ist die kiste
aber eine phishing dingens was zu essen
aber kein schwert das ist doch nicht
wahr sein
wir können zwischen dahin bringen dass
da noch so ein loch da wo das wasser
raus kommt okay dass ich schwimme schon
mal kratz zu einer anderen insel okay du
hast ein boot ja ich habe gut habe ich
ihm gesagt du bist du schon benutzt
ich gehe mal ganz alleine da auf den
turm und hoffe man dass da keiner ist
wenn doch ich angle wieder während das
schwimmen sie haben vorhin schon mal
games gespielt hat das wunderbar
geklappt nur dann wurde ich halt da ist
eine aber damit auch kein städter
niederrissen sollen wir uns zusammen
plattmachen komme schwimme vielleicht
kommt man lieber zu anderen inseln wo
ist der typ der ist dabei dem turm jetzt
ist ein wasser du ganz ehrlich ich
schwimme jetzt eben ins wasser ich mach
dem vom boot aus fertig ich würd's nicht
riskieren wenn du tot bist es das
relativ wird für die aufnahme
ich würd sagen wir gehen da zusammen
drauf hast du volles leben ja was schon
mal fisch und kommt das hast du eine
rose
nein ich habe hier eine hose für dich oh
oh cool ich hoffentlich fällt jetzt
nicht gleich ins wasser
natürlich schweißte die jan rand wir
können den jahr ein bisschen abgrenzen
dass er quasi er muss ja an ran kommen
irgendwann wieder
ja war der schon gegen turm
wahrscheinlich schon eher der hatte auch
eine volle läger halb fast volle leder
ristow gut wo ist dahin
der ist jetzt auf die andere kleinere
insel geschwommen und ich würde sagen
wir nehmen uns aber ganz einfach einmal
so ein bisschen durchs wasser ja
oder ich will das mal oben okay gut er
schwimmt naja ich okay er hat auch nur
angeln oder er hat ein schwert aber er
möchte es nicht zeigen weil er weiß dass
wir ihn sehen oder das werden jetzt die
ganz ganz große dominator gerüchte ich
glaube nicht dass ich mich vorher
gesehen hat und ich glaube auch nicht
dass er mich gesehen hat also es auf der
insel aber wenn wir das so hinter mir
her du bist ja oder nein nicht so
schnell nicht so schnell geht es dem
boot raus und bringt sie auch nicht
häufig unterwasserwelt okay du schaffst
es losgeht dass das auch wenn er sein
boot ist vor dem tor schießt ist einfach
es geht gar nicht
heute ist der typ jetzt auf der insel
darauf ganz oben ich guck da mal eben so
mit optischen zoom und so wäre wenn er
auf der insel drauf ist könnte es sein
dass er uns sieht aber da muss er ja
runter springen und wenn wir da zusammen
hängen müssen wir da eigentlich platten
du bist ja ich habe überlegt ob wir
nicht erst auf die ok daten heute
scheitert ein holzschwert räuber kirche
andere insel gehen wir mal schnell auf
die und des boots
wenn jetzt das boot und haben wir gehen
ein bisschen durchs wasser vielleicht
liegt uns nicht
der hat uns schon gesehen glaube ich
moment ich schaue an
ich habe gleich daneben der unterwasser
okay okay der test soll ich schnellste
boot und dann schwimme ich kann es einen
tisch lag wie uns auf jeden fall
er hat eine voller rüstung und ein
schwert alter wir haben hätte hat sich
eben die ganze zeit geknickt ich denke
das seltsam
ok ich schaue mal kurz hier oben nach ob
hier nicht irgendwo und geistlichen
gerade auch keine kiste ach du scheiße
ebenerdig schön lieber weg ich stand mir
das votum stunde gleich hinterher ich
will nicht dass das brot bekommt dann
ist er uns schneller hinterher
okay er bleibt am ufer stehen europa
kommt ins wasser misst er will mich
angeln mit einer angel bord das ist fies
aber dann schubst ich einfach nur weg
die lassen wir wieder zum turm schwimmen
ja dann können wir denn da hin wir unter
panschen oder so wenn es gehe ich aus
nashville becker schwimmbecken schwimmt
wieder zurück und schreiben zurück zur
insel gut damit sieht wahrscheinlich
dass wir auf dem wasser dann keine
chance hat sein dass der westen sich an
legt herrmann
was würdest du machen wenn ich sein wird
kaputt laut rumheulen und schlemmen oder
das will ich ja okay er bleibt wirklich
auf der insel das ist gut du bist guter
kollege bist einer von uns du brauner
bär kartoffeln einfach mal so ganz
indianisch aber der war hier schon drin
vermutlich ja der war hier
wahrscheinlich nicht erkennt sich
bestimmt auch ziemlich gut aus nämlich
man wahrscheinlich jetzt in diesem
wasser noch was nämlich immer dann wenn
wir doch erst die deutsche der insel
gegangen ist naja da geht ins wasser
loch ich glaube der kennt sich aus ich
stelle mir vor wie ich hat also diamant
rüstung und alles das boot geht
irgendwie kann ich kapuze die
normalerweise ist man machen kann so
wollen wir trotzdem nachkommen wenn ich
noch irgend was drin ist
du kannst das brot auch nicht kaputt
schlagen schade ich bin ja schon mal
nach und ist ein hund manche noch ein
wolf 10 10 mal probiert wir haben
hektisch lassen warte nicht dass der typ
und setzte noch hinterhergeschwommen
kommt
und der sich dein boot schnappt alter
witzlos haben sich überlegt schon wie
könnte er dann sein
der typ der mit jetzt wahrscheinlich
immer noch da hinten sein ich glaube
nicht also ich sehe den auf jeden fall
wenn er kommt und es kommt nichts auf
dem weg zur iss gut dann bin ich sagen
die meisten arbeiter hund kommt du
kommst du auch das geht dann wirklich
schaden
ich dachte das macht keine scheint es
ist ich glaube das ist ein bisschen
modifiziert muss selbstbewusst und so
und jetzt wird nach da drehe ich mal
ganz kurz die helligkeit ein bisschen
hoch so gut
der typ ist dann wahrscheinlich diesen
weg hier auch schon abgegangen
daher wird aus seiner sicht sie sind ja
wie was den typen da hinten wir sind
anderer arten und ich glaube da hat kein
schwert der hatten auch mehr haben und
wollte das ist kein hund von ihm
okay wir haben formal von draufgehen
okay würde ich auch sage ich mache jetzt
am besten als erstes wieder einmal ich
gta und dann auch drauf ist er unten
oder sind zwei eine warnung wieder ist
da und ist auf jeden fall auch noch so
einen alten baum ist da doch oder war
das ein schaf du ich habe angst gar
keiner ist
ich habe richtig angst der minecraft
bestes horror game sein also helfen kann
er denn sein
nicht dass das welt überrascht hier ja
krass der war doch warum die kommen erst
mal mit ich will aber auch nicht
herunterfallen
damit sich aber fast nichts mehr zum
essen nur noch einmal ich kann ich bin
noch sowas geben
ok und das weißt du wieviel ein
gebratener fisch an essen oft 23 ok dann
komme ich erst mal noch mit dem haus gut
ich mache jetzt auch erstmal den chat
komplett aus weil das in der pflicht
dann hätten so ist auf jeden fall besser
ich würde sagen wir umgehen das thema
ganz kurze könnte er dann sein
ich dachte mich darauf einmal von ingo
panisch oder so dann hast du immer noch
den hund stimmt aber der hund ist weit
weg von mir dass es irgendwie geht
sicher nicht zu den aufgaben eines aber
weggelaufen vor uns ich versuche mal
kurz nach unten zu gehen wo dieses licht
waren sie
naja ich bin direkt hinter dir gut das
ist so eine modifizierte map dies ganz
anders als die originale
wir sollten wirklich nicht mehr sprinten
das hier bestehe noch einen hund guckst
du hier und da etwas fester sind zum
jahren dh dann muss für ihn da stehen
also auf der linken seite dann kann ich
hier eben nachgucken
ich schaue mir okay ich kann hier auch
wenn ich da unten und teleportiert nicht
dass es gut ich hoffe mal dass ich das
jetzt gelohnt hat hier runter zu gehen
hugo ohne bohlen das heißt ich kann
jetzt pilzsuppe machen das ist unser
essen problem erst einmal gelöst da oben
ist die höhle aber man kann man nur von
oben rein wenn man sich darunter fallen
lässt war das ist blöd weil er so eine
komische ablage okay das heißt ja warte
mal ganz kürzlich kommen dahin es wenn
du pilze sie ist auf jeden fall abbauen
ja ich denke ich dass er nicht hier ist
auch nix drin
ich bin so richtig hermann ja ich werde
deinen namen von daher bleibt man ganz
gut stehen einige ganz wichtig aber
nicht mehr
okay okay ich weiß ja ungefähr ich sehe
ich aber schon außerhalb wegs gut dann
suche ich dich mal ach da bist du ja so
wartenberg erschwert wo ich jetzt runter
springen werde habe ich hoffe wenn wir
an nichts mehr drin ist ja nicht das
ganze im sonst riskiert hier so kann man
mit ich weiß schon was du meinst
diese leuchte trennung ja da hinten
seien schweine die kann mir doch töten
dann kriegen wir was zu essen
ich mache das grabmal ja gut ich bin da
mal rein ach du kacke leider fand
druckplatte da wird man runter geschubst
wieder kurz nein ich nicht tot
nur ich würde da ich bin da drauf
gesprungen und ich bin auch eine
druckplatte gesprungen weise nämlich
darunter geschubst hier kannst du da
wieder raus oder natürlich gar nicht
wieder raus okay was dann probiert der
partner weil man kann sich ja durchs
liegt am rand einer druckplatte die
druckplatte umgehen wenn man sich's
nicht tue ich weiß nicht ob da ja ja
erst geschafft ja ich stehe noch drauf
jetzt muss ich noch aufpassen dass ich
die druckplatte mit vergeht ja fast ist
auch nicht ganz
da kommt angeschwitzt einem zwischen
handschalter eine feder her sieht
zugleich aus dem tech speck gehen oder
glaubst du dass nichts mehr
ich glaube nicht dass da noch irgendwas
ist natürlich dass hier noch irgendwas
nicht jetzt auch nicht gut hier wird
wahrscheinlich eh schon alles leer sein
weil hier gerade einmal dieser eine typ
war
und dann noch dieser angriff von vorhin
wollen wir erstmal irgendwo im wald
laufen oder durch schweine getötet
aber ich habe ja so gesunde boot das
heißt essen haben wir genug wenn ihr
pilze farben hier ist ein hier sind
pilze ich habe zwei rot oder braun rote
übrigen blätter und so kam er kaputt
machen aber steine nicht
also leute bitte dann nicht rummeckern
das ist einfach so festgelegt
braune brauchen wir auch danach
pilzsuppe ja zwei brown habe ich auch
sein haus schon ein bisschen haus und
des gerichtes und kommt auch mit meinem
hund kann ja theoretisch die schweine
mit töten
was macht er wenn ich die angeleitete
das ist gut es ist erstmal wichtig und
natürlich braucht ein schwert ist
wichtig als alles andere
ok ich dann auch wieder und so macht er
nichts ich hab das oft ist aber alles
ein bisschen anders
ja ich glaube auch da und blitzen
so aber das war es jetzt auch schon
wieder für diese folge hunger games wir
sehen dann einfach in der nächsten folge
ich werde jetzt einfach weiter aufnehmen
wie immer wenn ihr das video gut fände
domhof eine schlecht seine daumen runter
und dann würde ich sagen sie wir uns in
der nächsten folge sowie von nur noch
sieben ja wir sind nur noch sieben
also wir befinden uns jetzt schon in der
zweiten folge nur damit du weißt dass er
stets sorgfältig das mal okay gut ich
verstehe jetzt nur noch sieben meinst du
wir haben 2 das sind gegner die wir
töten müssen er hat nicht wert ist schon
mal ja wir brauchen auf jeden fall ein
schwert wieder einer getötet gestorben
ja und noch 60 sekunden bis zum
deathmatch achte schalte ich werde mich
solange irgendwo eine ecke verkriechen
bis ich tot
bissig zwischen gepachtet ist ja okay
noch 45 sekunden kommt meiner liebe
leute dann war das gerade total blöd mit
dem cut zu machen sich reden machen
das sollte ich nicht reinmachen das
heißt jetzt noch irgendwie sonne dingens
dann wäre ich jetzt mal ganz schnell
runter zu laufen werde wir sind immer
noch in der gleichen episode
also bitte jetzt nicht verwundern dass
ich wollte das eigentlich kappen aber
irgendwie hab ich das dann doch nicht
weil jetzt her dass das match ist und
ich glaube ihr wisst was ich meine
ich habe ist eine strömung jetzt die
kiste ist sehr schwer hier kann man
nicht durch doch kann man schwer alles
möglich dass er drin war schnell schnell
hergeben
noch 15 sekunden schnell wir hatten
nicht viele schwerter ich habe nur ein
schwert aber ich kann eine art ist eben
dass man sich entscheiden
ich habe keine rüstung style western den
helm geben wir haben hätten wir gut
ich hasse noch 2 1 ok zu spät aber es
geht schon los
okay okay wir mal schnell die angst wir
sind erst mal zusammen
ja natürlich und dann reden wir übers
ländern kennen uns gegenseitig okay das
ist okay ich weiß sowieso schon gewinns
aber ich glaube die kisten sponsored
wieder voll oder ich will können zu
riskieren alter hier liegen kommt dann
ja ja sag hätten haben wollen wieder
voll ist ein hintern ja keiner die sind
hier gut
ich auch schnell als kompass ich brauche
ich werd ich habe ich werde für dich
hier ja ja ja ich weiß dass ich hier
hallo ich hatte da kommt einer golden
gehen das alter ich schaue mir gern
einmal die ganzen sachen von den anderen
merkt auch schon aus den kisten
natürlich kompass fisch also ich gucke
ich habe jetzt übels viele sachen aber
ich habe immer noch kein vernünftiges
schwerter ich hab nix bessers als ich
nicht vorher schon hatte du aber wenn
wir auf den typ mit den diamant schwert
von hinten gehen dann könnte das
vielleicht oder was wäre ja nicht sicher
der ex notiert uns aber jetzt geht auch
glaube ich gleich auf mich los ist wo
ich werde ich werde nicht auf den von
hinten jetzt drauf gehen am ende und es
in dem bericht
in den kisten dann braucht man es nicht
müssen uns dieser hat euro oder wir
machen so wenn zwei sich streiten freut
sich der dritte satz war schnell drauf
gehen dass draufgehen
okay okay okay gut noch nicht noch nicht
noch nicht
ich habe ein diamant schnitt scheiße ich
habe das rennen ich bin weg hatte ich
heute das aufnehmen ja ich schon lang in
up tut mir leid ich wollte das auch
nicht gut ich denke ich mag ihn von
hinten ja scheiße scheiße scheiße das
wird richtig eng
tatsächlich kommt sofort ich habe das
tierheim gerettet hätten wir hatten eine
lange debatte die lenkte ihn ab ich gehe
von hinten auf ihn los das wird dann
richtig gehandelt wie tatsächlich genug
ist kann schon ein kleiner schock kommen
wir drauf kommen oder wollten abwarten
dann weg na gut dann kam ich hab dann
glaube ich zwei diamanten ich mache
jetzt auch noch ein diamant schwerter
treffe ich den nicht ok ich muss mir auf
jeden fall jetzt verstehe ich auch nicht
gedacht dass wir so weit kommen
ich hätte auch nicht gedacht dass da
noch ein volles und so hatte der comcom
jetzt kommt mir fast hätte ich dich
geschlagen
na gut wenn der tod ist jetzt natürlich
sagen die wir beide noch mal unsere
ecken
wollen wir jetzt einfach weiter kämpfen
muss wir sind immer zwei oder oder ist
noch einer übrig startgemeinschaft ich
hab den stier aus ja ja wir sind nur
noch zwei wissen halt nicht das wird
jetzt oder wollen wir trollen
das wäre als das stimmt jetzt wollen wir
so gut geht los also ich hab ich es ist
so hilfe ich darf ja nicht sagen dass
jetzt machen
du würdest sein
das stimmt schon
ja da ist der weg da ist der sie ja dass
ich das ding noch mal gewinne ist vorbei
ja ich glaube schon
bitkom crafter vom distrikt endeavour
ich glaube dass restart inc ok meine
damen und herren das war es jetzt hier
mit einer langen folge hunger games 20
minuten mit ein paar verwirrungen
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass wir das
sich da dass wir beide noch ins finale
kommen ich auch nicht
das war echt extrem geil fand ich okay
wir sehen es dann in der nächsten folge
wie immer bewerten nicht vergessen
daumen hoch wenn das gut seiner daumen
runter wenn es nicht so gut findet und
von meiner seite tipps und der dominik
darf die letzten worte sagen
höchst heute hatte ich die letzten worte
[Musik]